to Saturday morning in Germany that's my
godson Paul he is playing soccer for his
club team so were a lot of kids in the
soccer obsessed country Paul lives in
the town of Rodin kirshen I have brought
Paul and his little brother Jakob the
keeper shirts from Manuel Neuer that's
the goalie for the German national team
soccer jerseys are the only form of
currency they accept that's not just me
buying their low sportswear companies
are competing for it to adidas the
second-largest sportswear company in the
world sponsors and partly owns Nora's
club team Bayern Munich adidas is based
in Germany it sponsors the national team
- soccer is the heart and soul of the
company Markus Bauman is adidas is
senior VP for global football it's part
of our DNA so everything started with
soccer back in the days with our founder
Adi Dassler
when he invented the first screw in
stats 54 for the German team to win the
World Cup the miracle of very lyrical of
bran of course dodge slumped a minge
Bala is talking about Germany's
unexpected win at the 1954 World Cup in
Switzerland it was the first televised
Cup it is still a big deal in Germany
and an adidas I think this is so rooted
soccer so rooted within the company the
last 60 years adidas has been the
world's leading brand in football which
is what the rest of the world calls
Soccer World Cup years like this one are
very good for the company so this year
is what adidas calls an event year what
does that mean it's a year where we'll
achieve a new record level of sales for
the first time we will break two billion
euro barrier in terms of net sales for
the category soccer that's about 2.7
billion dollars it starts with putting
national teams in the Dida's this summer
in Brazil 9 of 32 teams will be wearing
a dias we have great assets leading
Federation's the top ranked FIFA
Federation's like Germany Colombia
Argentina Spain the reigning world
champion
we have Japan we have Mexico and they
are all a great showcase for us as a
brand to the world
adidas also sponsors FIFA which runs the
World Cup but Nike sells soccer here too
and now it sells almost as much as
adidas football has always had these
magical moments
Trevor Edwards is president of Nike
brand we began you know in football did
you know let's say 1994 my business at
that time was about 40 million today
it's over 2 billion Nike is larger
outselling adidas and basketball running
an American football but adidas still
out sells Nike in soccer 2013 Nike says
it made 1.9 billion dollars on soccer
according to an industry estimate adidas
made 2.4 billion but Nike wants to own
the soccer market too football is the
number one sport around the world and to
be a truly global brand we had to
compete in football and that's the
reason why we have such a commitment to
the sport and we committed ourselves to
being a football company 365 days a year
that strategy is beginning to work for
Knight National League's in Germany in
the UK reach a global audience
year-round adidas is World Cup
sponsorship every four years doesn't
mean what it used to Nike is drawing
adidas into a simple and more expensive
game sponsor as many teams and players
as possible everyone follows their
favorite athletes when they see you know
great moments of brilliance from those
players they tend to love those this
doesn't mean like he ignores the World
Cup Nike is sponsoring 10 national teams
won more than adidas
and Nike has made ad that show some kind
of global soccer event they just never
mentioned the words FIFA World Cup
soccer marketing is simple make shirts
and shoes pay heroes to wear them kids
like heroes
Paul and Jakob like Manuel Neuer and if
no air ends up being the keeper for the
winning team in Brazil Paul Jakob and
Adidas will all have a very very good